ha sido un consejero de celensky
presente en esas negociaciones el que ha
confirmado la existencia de ese borrador
Un inicio de acuerdo entre rusos y
ucranianos según la parte ucraniana ese
inicio de acuerdo incluiría un cese de
la sostenidades una retirada de las
tropas y la búsqueda de apoyo
internacional a países como Estados
Unidos o Turquía hay dudas sobre esa
retirada de las tropas pero desde
Ucrania en los últimos días ya señalaban
que serían las tropas oficiales
regulares que llegaron aquí a partir del
24 de febrero con esta invasión y que no
formaría parte de ese acuerdo toda la
zona del Rusia por su parte sigue
insistiendo en un modelo de neutralidad
como países como Suecia o Austria en el
que podría Ucrania tener un ejército
propio pero sin embargo no formar parte
de la otan es la sexta Ronda de
negociaciones es un paso hacia adelante
pero sobre el terreno la guerra continúa
los ataques conti edificios de civiles
en cieza y un toque de queda Y ese es el
principal miedo que hay aquí en Ucrania
que este acuerdo no sea definitivo que
finalmente el kremlin no apoye este
acuerdo y que tan solo intenten ganar
tiempo para seguir sitiando ciudades y
conquistar más terreno de este país